[Music]
and then I wake up the next morning and
say we have to remodel Steve and Sabrina
just liked our photo Susan and I made a
commitment to make our commitment work
you know what that takes masochistic
guilt no it takes commitment I don't
know how to describe it but every part
of me is miserable miserable what am I
supposed to do now it's just gonna take
some time how long have you been coming
here 15 years you too
what are you up to now I thought from
that moment on of my breakup as my wake
up I was actually trying to think about
this divorce being in a whole new way
why not have a party a divorce point I
need to understand how by a guy that I
think is pretty normal only has one
guest tennis party Nate please look at
your invite chips and dip at the
Savannah and Express isn't it pretty
it's pathetic if you want to have a
successful divorce party you've gotta
treat this as it just won as if it was
as important as your wedding come help
me get over my ex-wife that sounds like
a party invites celebrate my divorce
[Applause]
[Music]
like to register for the beer mug set
ping pong table and the 65 inch 4k ultra
HDTV with crystal clear pure pixelation
is this for a wedding
no it's for divorce
[Music]
you